one of the most interesting parts of the
bitcoin network is the lightning network
in my opinion in order to understand the
lightning network though we have to
first go back and understand all sorts
of other layer ones and layer twos what
the hell does that mean well it's pretty
simple gold served as a layer one it
served as the security for economic
value for thousands of thousands of
years gold held value in the world in a
fantastic way but it wasn't exactly the
easiest thing to use if you think about
it gold's really heavy it's hard to
carry around if i just simply put down
some gold on the table you can't easily
tell how much is there from a value or a
unit standpoint on top of that if i show
up to a store and i need to only use a
fraction of the gold i either have to
shave it off or i have problems
transacting so gold was great as a store
of value it was great at securing that
economic value but it wasn't the easiest
thing in terms of actually using it in a
medium of exchange and so ultimately we
used gold as layer 1 that security layer
but then we built a layer 2 on top of it
this is where paper claims on the gold
occurred along the way somebody decided
rather than carry my gold around why
don't i simply leave my gold at a bank
or in a vault or at home and instead
i'll have a paper claim literally pieces
of paper that said you can redeem this
paper for gold and so if you had the
paper claim you could go to the bank or
the vault and say hey give me my one
ounce of gold or give me a bar of gold
for this piece of paper now all of a
sudden i didn't have to carry my gold
around i could simply carry around those
paper claims on the gold and i could
walk into any store or go up to any sort
of service provider and say hey here is
my paper claim to the gold it worked
just as well as gold because people knew
that they could redeem those paper
claims for the actual gold so layer 1
was all about security layer 2 was all
about usability or medium of exchange
well we're getting a replica of that in
the new digital financial system
bitcoins layer one is all about security
it optimizes for decentralization no one
controls it no one can change the
monetary policy bitcoins layer one is
the most decentralized most powerful
computer network in the world
but because it is optimizing for
security it makes direct trade-offs with
things around throughput and fees so at
times the bitcoin network can be slow or
it can actually have higher fees that's
intentional it's explicitly pursuing
security over high throughput or low
fees because ultimately bitcoin believes
similar to how history has created layer
ones and layer twos bitcoin is doing the
exact same thing bitcoins layer one is
all about security bitcoins layer two is
all about usability and that's where the
lightning network comes in bitcoin's
lightning network is all about
leveraging layer one for security and
layer two for that usability now you can
go ahead and you can send bitcoin to
anyone in the world instantaneously
completely for free
that is the beauty of the lightning
network layer one provides security
layer two provides high throughput and
low fees
now when you go ahead and you vertically
integrate
layer two the lightning network and
bitcoins layer one you get a highly
secure monetary system a highly secure
monetary asset along with all of the
usability promises of a decentralized
digital currency
now you can whip any amount of economic
value from fractions of a penny all the
way up to millions of dollars around the
world to anyone at any time without
asking permission by simply leveraging
the lightning network that gives you all
of the benefits of a digital currency
along with all the security of a
decentralized system i ultimately
believe people are drastically
underestimating how valuable the
lightning network will become over time
bitcoin's layer one has grown and
protected over a trillion dollars of
economic value the lightning network now
is going to unleash the usability of
that one plus trillion dollar market
asset as more and more people continue
to adopt the network you can use it you
can become a node operator and you can
also educate other people about it
go check out and learn more about the
lightning network because i think it'll
become the dominant payment system of
the world